salut comment ça va regardez regardez ce
que j'ai là alors bon on a un petit
reflet à cause de l'éclairage c'est le
Xiaomi c'est le mix fold 2 mix fold 2
qui n'est pas sorti en Europe qui n'est
pas sorti en France qui est un produit
de Chine mais que j'ai ici ça c'est
plutôt bien donc aujourd'hui l'exercice
on va l'unboxing on va le regarder on va
voir si il est intéressant on va voir
comment il est fait on va essayer de le
comparer un peu par rapport à la
référence aujourd'hui du marché en
France le Samsung Galaxy Z fold 4 donc
on va regarder ça et puis on va tout de
suite commencer par unboxing vous êtes
prêt allez on y va
alors regarde hop j'évite de tout
arracher ça c'est plutôt bien ah mais il
y avait ils ont fait ça bien ils ont mis
une étiquette et moi bien évidemment hop
j'ai pas fait gaffe donc on peut
l'ouvrir comme ça au lieu de passer par
la version sauvage alors déjà ça ça
vient se lever comme ça ok assez simple
alors ça c'est assez marrant parce qu'en
fait j'ai l'impression que je peux venir
me lever comme ça mais que pour autant
ça va se tirer comme ça fait de voir ah
voilà ça se tire comme ça expérience
très premium déjà ils ont vraiment voulu
mettre le paquet ici Xiaomi mix folle
c'est la deuxième version Xiaomi mi VIP
service j'ai un numéro de téléphone
alors je pense que c'est un numéro de
téléphone en Chine si vous voulez
essayer d'appeler faites-vous plaisir
voilà qu'est-ce que j'ai là-dedans ça
c'est rien c'est juste une petite carton
ok mix folder tout est écrit en chinois
bien évidemment c'est un produit qui est
destiné à la Chine donc tout sera écrit
si en chinois je ne parle pas le chinois
donc vous en douterez je l'avais déjà
pris en main à Munich je trouvais
extrêmement fin vous allez voir c'est
très très intéressant ensuite
instruction fine case donc là je dois
avoir une petite coque je pense ici
petite coque de protection c'est une
espèce de plastique et qu'un espèce de
de cuir là vous voyez il fait cuire
assez sympa griffé Xiaomi est-ce qu'il y
a un truc là qui se tire ici ou pas ah
oui ça vous fait l'espace de petit
trépied pour venir le poser en mode
lecture ça c'est très très malin on
regardera après donc ça c'est tout ce
qu'on a là-dedans on va voir un
adaptateur en USB C ici pour venir le
recharger plus du coup ouvrir le tiroir
de carte SIM qui est situé juste ici il
y a un truc rouge intérieur c'est quoi
ça faites voir ah c'est pas un truc
rouge c'est qu'en fait là vous voyez ils
l'ont mis en rouge là à l'intérieur ça
c'est joli bon ok ça reste un câble donc
c'est assez standard on va pas
s'éterniser là-dessus de l'autre côté
qu'est-ce qu'on a un adaptateur jack
USB C parce qu'on a pas de prise jack
ici ok why not ensuite ici on le voit
hein chargeur 67 watts donc ici
effectivement on a un petit bloc de chat
67 watts comme on est sur un truc
chinois et bien on va fatalement avoir
un bug de charge dédié à la Chine ok ce
qui nous intéresse nous c'est de venir
voir ce qu'ici là alors attendez mix
folle ils ont mis comme un espèce de
petit sertissage là pour être sûr qu'il
a jamais été ouvert alors si je viens
tirer ce truc là de voir regarde c'est
la petite preuve qu'il a jamais été
ouvert qu'il est tout neuf bon ben alors
le coup il est plus trop tout neuf
maintenant ensuite
ok ah c'était transparent donc il me
garde la petite partie avec le numéro de
série que nous on s'enlève le truc que
je trouve dingue c'est que ça c'est fin
et on a un très très grand écran à
l'avant légèrement incurvé sur le côté
ici et bien écoutez pas grand chose et
ce gros bloc photo alors qui se détache
réellement quand même on le voit
vraiment la détacher mais normalement si
je viens mettre la coque arrière il est
vraiment à l'intérieur donc pour le coup
il est protégé je peux venir prendre
comme ça ça va pas bouger et si je viens
ouvrir ça ils m'ont mis une petite
flèche a vraiment pour savoir par où il
faut que je vienne l'ouvrir vous voyez
la petite flèche donc là je prends je
viens l'ouvrir et ça me permet de le
poser comme ça si je veux venir regarder
du contenu ou si je l'ouvre en grand et
que j'ai regardé du contenu ok bon allez
on va maintenant le configurer bon on
reprend mais hop voilà on ferme ça il y
a trop de lumière comme ça on est pas
mal alors on continue regardez je vais
me faire l'installation complète du
produit donc là il a installé il est
fonctionnel ça c'est cool déjà le truc
que je trouve très très bien c'est que
l'écran est grand alors il y a un truc
qui me perturbe un petit peu c'est que
bien que l'écran soit grand comme il est
légèrement incurvé voyez sur le côté et
bien il y a un truc qui est un peu
bizarre au niveau visuel il y a un côté
un peu asymétrique parce que d'un côté
ici on vient terminer en angle droit et
on n'est pas incurvé et de l'autre côté
on voit qu'on est légèrement incurvé bon
c'est pas extrêmement grave ce que
j'aime bien par contre tout de suite ici
c'est que on a un très grand écran ici
on peut vraiment venir en profiter sur
la face avant ça c'est super bien le
cadre noir me convient bien et lorsque
je viens l'ouvrir ensuite à l'intérieur
car là j'ai un écran qui est énorme et
ça c'est assez cool donc très très bel
écran alors on est ici sur mewaii 13
fold c'est vraiment une édition spéciale
pour le fold et qui globalement est
plutôt bien alors c'est une version
complètement chinoise donc totalement je
ne parle pas le chinois voyez hop là on
a toutes les apps chinoises ici je vais
pas avoir les services Google ici je
vais pas avoir Youtube je vais pas avoir
grand chose donc de toute façon c'est
pas un produit que je peux venir
recommander aujourd'hui mais c'est
intéressant de le regarder pour voir
vraiment l'innovation du côté de chez
Xiaomi alors faites voir cette charnière
ce que ça raconte au niveau de
l'ouverture ça c'est marrant ça parce
que vous voyez je le prends comme ça on
le sent il ferme élément par élément on
tient bien et là quand on arrive à une
ouverture un peu plus vers la moitié à
peu près voyez il souffre tout seul elle
est toute cette partie là en fait la
moitié là elle est pas du tout tenue
alors c'est pas très grave mais c'est
vrai que c'est un peu surprenant quand
on a l'habitude de prendre d'autres
smartphones là j'ai le Z fold 4 de
Samsung et lorsque je l'ouvoyais il
reste comme ça là c'est à moi de
l'accompagner jusqu'au bout la
différence c'est que celui de Xiaomi pas
du tout celui de Xiaomi il tient pas bon
après est-ce que c'est grave c'est pas
très grave alors c'est vraiment
intéressant de regarder ces deux
produits pourquoi parce que en fait
aujourd'hui en Europe en France la
référence c'est celui-là c'est le Z
folka qui a pas d'autres produits qui
viennent réellement en face de Samsung
que ce soit sur le zflip ou sur le
zenfold donc si vous regardez je les
prends et je les mets un peu face à face
tous les deux trucs qui est vraiment
flagrant c'est que du côté de chez
Xiaomi on a un écran qui est beaucoup
plus grand sur la face avant et ça c'est
quand même vachement cool tandis que
l'autre côté chez Samsung c'est pas du
tout la même taille et c'est vrai que
l'expérience là-dessus Xiaomi est quand
même un peu mieux parce que plus grand
alors après il y a ce côté incurvé sur
le côté qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
mais l'écran en tout cas avant de Xiaomi
est beaucoup plus fonctionnel que celui
de Samsung on se parle ici d'une dalle
de 6,56 ça c'est quand même bien le
tactile fonctionne vraiment bien la
charnière je vous dis l'ouverture est
vraiment différente jusque là ça se
tient et dès qu'on arrive à la moitié ça
s'ouvre un peu tout seul ça fait un peu
moins un peu moins premium ce truc là
quoi voyez un peu perturbant alors
regardez ça c'est assez marrant point de
détails sur ce smartphone là dessus il y
a marqué 100 bail Arman Cardone Harman
Kardon ça fait partie du groupe Samsung
très rigolo à la différence regardez
même au niveau de la taille de l'écran
intérieur il est plus grand que le Z
fold 4 on est sur 8,0 de pouce alors
c'est ici une dalle OLED également il
est un peu plus grand en termes de
taille légèrement plus haut mais pas
grand-chose surtout plus large donc ça
c'est vachement cool on sent moins la
charnière ici là alors voyez par contre
ce qui est assez marrant c'est que ici
on a une charnière goutte d'eau c'est à
dire que regardez voyez il se plie là
comme ça et il est totalement collé et
normalement lorsqu'on a ça et bien on se
retrouve à ne pas trop sentir la pliure
sous le doigt ça sent moins sur le mix
folle 2 que sur le Z fold 4 je chie avec
ces noms parce que je les trouve
vraiment pas extrêmement évident Z fold
4 mix fold 2 en termes de marketing ils
ont vraiment des noms à coucher dehors
les marques là-dessus c'est un peu
galère cette pliure je la sens un petit
peu moins mais elle est quand même
présente par rapport à Samsung où là
elle est quand même vachement plus
présent donc ça c'est vraiment un truc à
venir améliorer du côté de chez Samsung
ne plus sentir cette charnière ça serait
quand même vachement bien j'aime
beaucoup aussi au niveau de la copie de
Xiaomi c'est cette finesse on n'a pas du
tout la même finesse il est beaucoup
plus fin que le zedfall de 4 regardez là
alors il est plus haut il est surtout
vachement plus fin alors le bloc photo
par contre ça rajoute un côté un peu
fatal s'il est assez épais là mais par
contre si on prend juste là il est quand
même vachement plus fin vous voyez c'est
quand même assez important on le sent
vachement donc c'est vrai qu'il y a un
côté vachement plus agréable en tenue de
main que si on prend le Z fold 4 vous
voyez comme ça là il est quand même un
peu plus fatal ça le modèle de Samsung
après il y a des avantages et des
inconvénients de chaque côté le gros
truc que je vais vachement aimé ici déjà
effectivement je vous dis c'est cet
écran extérieur l'écran intérieur aussi
très bien alors attention et ça il faut
le savoir à la différence de la copie de
Samsung ici vous n'avez aucune caméra à
l'intérieur là où nous a mis une petite
caméra sous l'écran alors ça c'est
vachement bien parce que Samsung a une
super technologie ici où il y a cette
caméra qui est sous l'écran ici alors
cette caméra sous l'écran elle est bien
c'est pas une caméra d'une super qualité
mais si on veut pouvoir avoir son
smartphone en face ouvert et être filmé
en même temps on peut venir le faire
chez Xiaomi aujourd'hui c'est pas
possible donc ça c'est aussi un point un
peu différenciant après on va regarder
ce qu'on a du côté des caméras alors
regarde c'est très marrant parce que ils
ont récupéré puis pas longtemps Xiaomi
le partenariat avec Leica jusqu'à
présent c'était Huawei qu'il l'avait
mais aujourd'hui ils l'ont plus donc on
a trois parties photos on va avoir un
grand angle de 50 mégapixels que bref un
point 8 on va avoir un ultra grand temps
je pense que c'est celui-là de 13
mégapixels que bref 2.4 et puis on noter
l'objectif x 2 du megapixels ok bon et
une caméra de selfie qui là par contre
est situé up la regarder juste ici la
caméra de selfie qui est là faudra voir
si c'est bien ou pas j'en sais
strictement rien aujourd'hui et je
switch à l'intérieur et là j'ai ma
caméra là vous voyez où je vois mon
moniteur en face l'ultra grand-angle le
X 2 d'un point de vue soft ça fonctionne
bien on a le Leica vibrant ou Leica
authentique ça c'est une colorimétrie
signée Laïka en fait vous voyez
un truc aussi fin sont obligés de venir
faire genre de choses wifi 6e enfin bref
on a la complète donc ici Xiaomi a
vraiment mis le paquet moi ce qui
m'intéresse sur ce produit là c'est déjà
la finesse ça c'est quand même vachement
cool la légèreté j'aime bien les
finitions gros point positif par rapport
au Galaxy Z fold 4 et bien c'est qu'on a
un écran qui est quand même vachement
plus grand qui est appréciable on sent
moins la pliure même si on la sent alors
que j'ai déjà vu d'autres produits où on
la sentait pas donc bon ça c'est encore
des trucs à venir améliorer je trouve
très joli je trouve premium il y a un
truc qui reste très surprenant avec
cette petite charnière vous voyez qu'il
ne tient pas du tout même là voyez elle
revient là je laisse ce coup un peu fait
de voir et elle revient ça c'est un truc
à venir corriger il y a un côté un peu
dérangeant on a l'impression que c'est
pas assez premium au niveau de la
charnière par contre j'adore cet écran
extérieur je trouve vraiment vraiment
bien c'est marrant parce que quand on
prend le mix fold 2 dans les mains et
qu'on a le Z fold 4 à côté et bien on a
l'impression qu'on a une nouvelle
génération ou une ancienne génération
alors que Z fold 2 4 est sorti il y a
pas longtemps donc là-dessus xiaomiya
quand même vachement mis le paquet il
sort un truc qui est quand même hyper
bien
pas non plus être complètement fou on le
verra pas arriver mais il faut
reconnaître que Xiaomi a bien bossé et
surtout ce qui viennent montrer avec ce
produit même si aujourd'hui il est
destiné à la Chine et bien c'est qu'ils
sont en capacité de fabriquer des
produits aussi premium que ce que nous
propose Samsung de l'autre côté alors
pour l'instant Samsung je peux vous
assurer son relativement tranquille
parce qu'ils sont les seuls en Europe et
en France sur le pliable on voit que les
autres travaillent dessus très très
sérieusement d'ailleurs je vous
montrerai un autre produit très bientôt
sur un smartphone qui se plie d'une
autre marque chinoise également même si
je pense aussi qu'il n'arrivera pas en
France pour l'instant Samsung encore un
peu le monopole ici au niveau des
smartphones qui se plie mais attention
les Chinois font des produits de
superbes qualités et quand on voit un
mix fold 2 ça peut vraiment envoyer du
lourd du fantasme voilà donc bon
dites-moi vous ce que vous en pensez
comment vous le trouvez ce produit dites
le moi en bas dans les commentaires on
en reparlera de tout ça on reparlera on
regardera l'année prochaine peut-être
qu'en 2023 je suis omi finira par
arriver avec un smartphone il y a
peut-être on n'est pas sûr mais
peut-être on regardera ça donc d'ici là
et bien écoutez on en reparle restez
connectés abonnez-vous et prenez soin de
vous il y a très bientôt des bisous
beaucoup d'amour à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]